let's jump into the first story so i
covered this uh on my main channel but
this is huge i think we're gonna have a
really fun conversation
from reuters losses on short positions
in u.s firms top
70 billion dollars so i'll just
that's the news there it is boom they
say what is it 5 000
firms uh the loss chasing shorted
companies became a trend among retail
traders rippling across the u.s markets
and
europe or texas data showed as of
wednesday there were loss making short
positions on more than 5
000 u.s firms to put it simply
what you are seeing in the great
gamestop rebellion
it's uh some people are calling it
occupy wall street 2.0
the new slogan being power to the
players of course that's that was the
chant of occupy as most of you know it
is now i suppose
but you know what's really crazy they
destroyed our businesses they shut
everything down they locked everyone up
everyone got really really angry and did
a bunch of different things with that
with that anger
and then when the riots stopped over
black lives matter and then we saw the
storm of the capital there's still that
anger it's not going anywhere
and then all of a sudden these uh
redditors
were like yo we're gonna short squeeze
these hedge funds out of billions of
dollars
and here's what i don't think i think
people don't realize and often when it
comes to online activism
the initial activists are probably just
doing it for the lulz it's funny
so wall street bets are like we make
money we tell people hey we're gonna buy
this the price goes up and then they
gamble right but then some
real angry people saw it populists on
the left and the right saw what was
happening
and thought i like i like the results of
this
and now before it was just these wall
street vets
bored young people with stimulus checks
now you've got a bunch of
righteous indignation i suppose people
who aren't don't know what stocks are
don't know how trading works aren't on
robinhood
aren't on any of these apps and they're
like i'm in and they throw their money
at it
so what's happening now is i mentioned
this in the in the intro
these wall street firms their exposure
is nearly infinite
the shorts can keep climbing as the
value keeps growing
but for most of these people that are
thrown in a couple bucks or thrown in a
couple hundred bucks
their risk is literally just that money
if i buy a stock for 10 bucks
and the stock hits zero i lost 10 bucks
i don't care but if you have
five million people doing that all
putting in that money now you've got 50
million
dollars invested in these companies sure
50 million dollars could be lost but for
an individual it's not that much
so this is what's happening now the
power of the people in play
a concerted effort it's almost like
everybody's shining a flash at the same
time creating this
massive blinding light essentially what
happened here
is a bunch of people got together on the
internet and outsmarted the hedge funds
the hedge funds aren't that smart to
begin with right and they literally
they literally outplayed them in their
own game and
what did the the the controllers of this
game do what did the billionaires do
well
they flipped the table over and made it
illegal for people to even
win on main street unless you're part of
the secret group on wall street they
colluded together they delisted a whole
bunch of stocks to of course
make them go broke and this is the
insanity of it they're
conspiring colluding together to make
sure
businesses go out of business for the
benefit of vultures that are going to be
making money off of that stock going
down
they're making sure companies no longer
have
money to function with this is
absolutely insane you know
you know what i was thinking when donald
trump got elected i was like wow the
elites sure screwed this one up the
establishment really messed this up
donald trump wasn't supposed to get like
they're supposed to be hillary right
something went wrong and i thought to
myself it's interesting because a lot of
people think the elections have always
been rigged
at least for a long time and then when
they discovered that trump won
they weren't or maybe whatever but the
idea was like wow you could actually
vote and it works right
i thought to myself if that conspiracy
is true
that the elections have always been
rigged and there's a uniparty that
controls everything
this current generation of establishment
political elites are the worst
it's almost like you know like you have
a kid and the kids just really bad at
everything like
you know you're the best skateboard in
the world you have a kid and your kid
just sucks at it
that's it this new generation of
establishment elites are just too dumb
to maintain the stranglehold over the
people
that's been enjoyed for some time i'm
saying assuming that conspiracy would be
true i'm not saying it is
but more importantly just look because
that's what people were saying like how
did this happen how to trump well trump
won it shows you that you can
but looking at the hedge fund screwing
all this up colluding with
big tech they're doing it right in front
of us
when they're i woke up this morning it's
like i was looking at my nokia stock and
the price is going down
and i'm like i can't buy any i want to
buy the dip it won't let me
they're forcing the market to crash it
is so
obvious what they've what they're doing
to rig the game now and everyone's just
watching them do it you're referencing
like apps like robin hood which is just
cut off trading
to people no no no only buying only
buying which means you can sell it to
the fat cats
so the price can go down but you can't
buy it back yeah for full disclosure
just for the lows i bought amc
i bought bed bath and beyond and nokia
all of them going down and and you you
can't buy
more you can only sell it which means
the price can only go down at least on
these apps
you've got to go to other platforms if
you want to try and buy it so this is
like the establishment
bankrupting these companies you know
these companies are
losing people investing into them
because again
a special billionaire circle of
individuals that are connected
to citadel that are connected to all
these larger companies again also full
transparency of what i just invested in
not a financial advisor you got to say
these things just to make sure you got
your
your eyes dotted and t's crossed here
but but they're
i mean dave portnoy really really said
something that that really makes sense
to a lot of people and a lot of people
are
repeating this what lock him up and he
just said jail
jail jail for all of them and i agree
put him in jail all right i know it's
not going to happen because we have
individuals like janet yellen at the
helm sorry you had something to say
but i think that one thing that's
amazing about it is that folks are
probably understanding that
they can even if you don't have much you
could still
do something amazing and great and start
to take back some of the power
i don't think people really realize if
they harness that energy what they could
really do with it
and so i think that this is just a
slight taste of what like
the plebs see this is like return to the
pledge this is revenge of the plebs like
you'll see like i think that that's
really amazing when people start to
realize that power
yeah you know well not just that but but
realizing that the markets are being
manipulated yeah they're bogus
they're protecting the wealthiest and
most powerful people in the
establishment
in exchange for screwing over well after
the hard time we've all have just been
going through
that's a triple slash and the stock
market benefiting from it
it's pretty mean yeah so let them show
your let them show their true colors
and let everybody see it for what it is
so robin hood emailed me
i got this email a lot of people have
already gotten it i guess it's coming
out in
it's staggered or whatever and they say
an update on market conditions
hi timothy it's been a tough day and
we're grateful should i should i do it
more like a snooty
like yeah give us more
we're grateful for you being a robin
hood customer
in light of the extraordinary market
conditions this week
we temporarily limited buying for
certain securities this morning
starting tomorrow we plan to allow
limited buys of these securities
we'll continue to monitor the situation
and may make adjustments as needed uh i
just want to say i'm not a financial
advisor
and you know i'm just giving my personal
opinion and i'll tell you what i want to
do
you know what i want to do tomorrow what
limited buys
what's limited mean because i'm going to
hit the max i'm going to hit that limit
right away boom first thing to be
determined
yeah i'm offended by what they did i am
too yeah they say this was a temporary
decision made to
made to best continue serving you oh
destroying the value of the stock that
i'm holding
served me well thanks as a brokerage
firm we
we have many financial requirements
including sec net capital obligations
and clearinghouse deposits
some of these requirements fluctuate
based on volatility in the markets
and can be substantial in the current
environment these requirements exist
to protect investors and the markets and
and the markets
and we take our responsibilities to
comply with them seriously
including to the measures we have taken
today to be clear this decision was not
made on the direction of any market
maker
we route to other market participants
you know they just admitted to
they said that their requirements the
sec capital obligations clearinghouse
deposits they had to do it right
they just said an email to me tim
you [ __ ] the game is rigged we're
telling you it's rigged
when the game is set up in such a way
that you benefit the sec requires us
to jam okay i'm not going to get that
offensive it's a family-friendly show
calm down requires us to slap you in the
face
that's right so when the hedge funds
burn the country to the ground
but they're too big to fail we better
give them some money off your back
how many people suffered 12 years ago
how many people's homes were under water
and still are and it's true for a lot of
people and they're telling you right now
but there are certain capital
obligations the sec requires of us
what they just said to me when you get
it right and you guys figure the game
out
the system requires that we smack you in
the face and knock you down
i don't care to read the rest of this
garbage we stand in support of you our
customers oh it's written in bold
oh it's amazing you believe it a little
more
it's like it's like they're urinating on
you and telling you it's raining yeah
but you guys this is like this is the
tails all this time they've been doing
listen i know this is a taylor's all
this time yeah if you're just getting
hit to it this is how it's always been
so we have to be the change but listen
that's it you're right
but we thought the system was was was
weighted
you know what i mean we thought the die
we yeah
we thought the system was weighted most
people i should say folks are coming to
the conclusion
what i'm saying is most people think
that the die is loaded
it can still land on seven you can still
win it's just really hard
yeah now we're learning they got some
kind of gizmo in it and they flick a
button and it always lands
for them snake eyes no no no no matter
what you lose they took the dice and
they rammed it up where the sun doesn't
shine
and they're telling you go do a little
happy dance with your little dice inside
of you and good luck getting anything in
there but also
the most other surprising aspect for a
lot of people
it isn't for us because we cover this we
know the game is right for a while and
you bring up some good points here is
the reaction from
big tech in the mainstream media
according to reuters
facebook has taken down the popular wall
street discussion group
robin hood stock traders and and also
another group so facebook is banning it
we heard discord's banning it but
we saw cnn yesterday describe this to
trumpism
yeah npr was talking about here we go
liking
this to gamergate because of harassment
of hedge fund managers
there's mainstream media journalists who
are tweeting out annoyed gifts
who are saying oh this is just like
gamergate are you trying it's not gonna
work
yeah but my point before was just that
the system before was rigged we all
thought so now we're learning it's not
that it's rigged
because even in a rigged system you
think you can find a way to get through
no no this this system is not just
rigged there's bodyguards blocking you
if you actually make it past a certain
threshold they're like no no
that wasn't supposed to happen get out
there's it's a big club you ain't in it
and there's no open door for anyone i
support the united states constitution
i'm an american
i love our country and our laws and a
lot of them but
i don't support the federal reserve in
the u.s dollar
right now i am totally out and off and
have lost total confidence in that
machination
i think it is ridiculous to trust that
system right now
and if that makes me sound un-american
that's a big problem
because the federal reserve is not an
american company well we have to
understand
the previous federal reserve chairman
janet yellen is now
the head of the treasury department and
the biden administration was
literally literally literally asked
today are you guys going to do anything
about this where's the press conference
is there going to be some news about
this
they responded with by saying uh
especially when asked about janet yellen
getting eight hundred and ten
thousand dollars from the citadel group
the citadel group by the way
is the one that invests in melvin
capital it's the one
that also robin hood's uh it's robin
hood's
smart wait it's a woman treasure
secretary yeah yes oh
well we're good yeah yeah thanks for
hanging out everybody
uh but but you brought up a good point
because
if you think someone's giving a 45
minute speech for 810 thousand
dollars for wisdom you're absolutely
idiotic and stupid when you're paying
someone
that large sum of money she got 7.2
million dollars from wall street firms
within two years for speeches
when you're giving her that much money
you're not buying wisdom
you're buying uh influence you're buying
someone that's going to be
that's going to be doing your bidding
and that's exactly what we're seeing
with this larger inaction here why
didn't you just start a non-profit
that they could donate to yeah you know
that's that's that's the way you get
away with it
they i i can't i love it when you know
hillary clinton went around doing
speeches for goldman sachs
just before she announced he was going
to run for president you you had a bunch
of journalists even saying
oh hillary clinton hasn't announced yet
but she just gave a 200 000
45 minute speech that's their donation
to her campaign
and she's gonna run that's how people
know yeah it's dirty politics it's dirty
it's the dirty markets and i'll tell you
what gets here because we've talked
about it quite a bit since this
gamergate
gamer gamestop rebellion there we go
gamestop rebellion there you go
when people try to vote and whether it's
bernie or trump
they end up losing now bernie lost twice
trump got in for four years then he
loses now people are feeling like their
vote's just not going to get them what
they want
i mean people voted for biden because
they hated trump and now they're stuck
with biden
janet yellen they're not happy about
that so what happens when that doesn't
work well now they're going to financial
markets because they're bored they've
got nothing to do
and these and and you're seeing these
super rich people freaking out getting
angry about it
but the people you know idol was saying
idol hands the devil's playground yes
well that's that's something that the
wall street fund should be saying right
now
because you've got a you've got an
economy shuttered
and a bunch of people sitting around
saying what do i do i'm angry
and then some dude goes hey you know
that stimulus check you got they just
put a little bit into this stock they'll
lose billions of dollars
okay click i'm done that's it it was a
simple click for so many people
and then they got to sit back and watch
the news and see the true power they
really had by simply
clicking a button let me tell you we
lifted a very heavy heavy box the other
day
it was like 200 something pounds and
we're like oh this is going to be rough
but we had four people
it was not even hard we didn't even
realize they asked they didn't ask you
to help
i was sleeping i bet you were but the
point is i bet you were
it's a really basic principle we all
know you guys ever do that light as a
feather stiff as a board thing
yeah wait listen let's not go down this
road you guys already have me out here
on this like in the middle of nowhere
magically i have to stay at this house
tonight though let's not talk about some
light as a feather stiff as a board you
guys are not going to voodoo
to meet and you played that game okay
we're not doing that tonight okay
the point i'm making though is when you
have a bunch of people trying to
lift 100 100 to 200 pounds it's like you
can use a couple fingers and it's like
whoa it doesn't it's like it's crazy how
easy it is to lift a person
exactly yeah and that's what it is it's
five million people
on wall street bets right now saying bro
i got a couple bucks to fire off just
tell me where to point it
and it's legal and they're freaking out
the sec is like we're gonna look into
this and do something about it
good luck so they're voting beautiful i
think it's beautiful i think it's
beautiful
that folks are doing this i agree and
and i hope that it makes a
you know i hope that it makes it change
do you think that there's going to be an
occupy
2.0 yeah this is it what's the move well
i mean but like what are we talking how
does this play out then
so one question i think this is the
beginning
the the the wall street vets and now all
of the angry people have found
the the the you know fusion reactor weak
point of the wall street death star
now they can try and rebuild you know so
just to get more
more literal they can block the selling
of these stocks
and i'm sitting here laughing like bro
we know what stocks your funds are
shorting
there's websites just showing you where
it's happening so if you ban gamestop
and you get you ban
amc and nokia and bed bath and beyond
and american airlines whatever keep
doing it
eventually you have to ban the sale of
every single stock because then all it's
going to happen is some dude's gonna be
like
hey guys they banned all the stocks
invest in this company and then they'll
point to a different one never go yeah
and then everyone floods that company
and
blows up the hedge fund yeah and then
they'll be quick quick ban that one
well just keep doing it weeks ago i've
been telling people there's gonna
there's going to be a new occupy wall
street movement coming
it's here no one knows exactly where
it's gonna go when it's when it's gonna
go
next but the shot was heard around the
world yesterday there was individuals
and people saying wow i made some money
i'm finally
able to pay off some of my mortgage i'm
finally able to pay off some of my
medical bills some of the stories of
individuals
saying you know heartbreaking things
that they're finally able to do
in this entire rig system and then today
the walls keep crashing down and they
can't do
nothing they can't buy more they could
only sell and most of the people are
watching their stock
be absolutely obliterated and destroyed
all for the personal benefits of a few
hedge funds managers who want to make
sure that they have the prettiest
biggest yacht
you know you know in martha's vineyard
next to barack obama's
you know big property plot land that of
course gives also a ton of wall street
speeches
uh like all these other you know
politicians that have a revolving door
amongst wall street amongst of course
all politicians who who just don't give
a damn about us and essentially just
serve them
so i feel like we're voted with our
votes and a lot of people feel
disenfranchised by that system because
of hillary clinton's email scandal that
seems to you know
undermine bernie and then the donald
trump fiasco all these people are like
where'd their voter front
and now they voted with their dollar and
now we're being told we can't even do
that
yeah well i'll just say this my
suggestion
is that if you carry a head with where i
think this might go
learn from situations past and keep
the movement pure don't put too much
extra sauce on it don't make it about
things that it's not about
keep the movement pure yeah people are
already trying
keep it about the people does that make
sense is that a clean way to say it
there have already been a bunch of
people who are like guys that's so smart
of you to buy this one stock
what about buying the stock that i've
invested in because there
there are people who are greedy there
are people who are trying to pump
other stocks or whatever but this is
specifically about short squeezing out
hedge funds
and so this is what you got to be
careful of
people are going to come in look these
hedge funds are going to do everything
in their power to try and shut this down
so they're already trying to get all
these people to either buy silver or
bitcoin or other things
and if that happens then interest moves
away from targeting the hedge funds
and the hedge funds the crypto market is
up 11 in the last 24 hours
could be coincidence because it
fluctuates like that but it's gone from
i don't know
900 billion to 1 trillion yeah i'm
hearing that a lot of whales are moving
their
like stable coins into the the you know
exchanges now so that's some of the
scuttlebutt going around as well
but again a lot of speculation in that
market and as you could say it could be
manipulated to make sure that these kind
of more targeted attacks don't work
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you